I'm here with Tom Pryor what do you do
here Tom that's a tough one I spend most
my time thinking about how to make the
website better other content and you can
look at the website the videos how they
string together all the exercises how
can we make that better for students and
make it better for people making it
content to put the content on the
website well what's that rule called
that's a product manager product manager
yeah so that's what all product managers
do oh yeah I think most product managers
will probably tell you it was something
very different even just in our role I
think part of it is being the glue to
make sure that whatever needs to happen
that other folks aren't doing happens
and that varies so much depending on
your team the rest of the people you're
working with and what your skills are so
we all do similar things and just making
sure that what we think is necessary
what the organization thinks it's great
for the site or the apps happen but day
to day that could that can be totally
different just from single day to date
versus different people can be working
on very different things well what is it
indicative day well maybe that every day
is the same yeah except it day so
yesterday I spent the first half of the
morning looking at different projects
that some of my team members were
working on and one of them was
rethinking our video page and how can
that be how can we have all of our other
content on there so users can find that
easily another one was thinking about
how can users ask questions of each
other on the site and get them answered
quickly now with the small projects
maybe two to four weeks long and then
the other half of the day I spent with
our head of content and had a product
thinking about what are we going to
launch a back-to-school time in
September and what are we going to
launch at the end of the year and then
how do we work backwards and so that was
long-term thinking out and it's not
thinking from two weeks to four weeks or
what's going to happen tomorrow when the
project starts but what where do we want
to be at the end of the year so when you
talk about these projects like these
projects to
you know rethink say the video page who
works on that like who makes that happen
yeah so that is our designers and our
engineers who are pretty fantastic and a
lot of the time could do all of this all
of the job without any help from me or
even an engineer and they're pretty
multi-talented but if we want to hear
box people for ease of understanding a
design we'll work towards the start of a
project saying what's the objective for
the user what's the user experience
okay what's the the workflow that we
want the user to have to get that
experience and and then later on how can
that look visually actually on the app
or the side a lot of people associate
design with only that last part yeah
Jules but that's only as that's only a
part of this what's the whole experience
we could be like yeah those it's
definitely the last piece is probably
the easiest piece most of them will tell
you getting understanding emphasizing in
the user is the toughest part and making
sure that what you are building just the
building the basics of it match to what
the user wants is really tough and after
that you know there's a few different
ways you can design it and then build it
but the designers will spend a lot of
the time that's what the designer does
who else is typically on these teams and
then engineers will be on there as well
we've got different flavors of engineers
who have different skills some of them
can mainly work on what it looks like to
the user of the front end so what yeah
the user interface and others will work
on the back end of how all of the things
are moving behind that you never see
working what are those because I think
for people what is a back-end mean yeah
it could mean like the knowledge map for
example the statistical model of well we
know that most people who got that
question you just got right also know
these things so we're not going to ask
you as many questions in that organ
assume that you know that and push you
up to another level that's on the data
science piece and also all of all of the
data where does that live yeah how do we
make sure that the website is running
fast because you know we're trying to
optimize the milliseconds or when that
video loads all of that you don't really
see about a lot of
there's tens of developers here working
on that and a lot of effort goes into
making that as smooth and as fast as
possible and then so I get the designer
I get what the engineers are doing and
then the role the product manager is is
to try and help them to do their job as
best they can essentially which and you
know maybe maybe if they're fantastic
we're not needed but it's there
yeah let's be really sure and fill in
those gaps and so a lot of the time
it'll it'll be mostly involved in it'll
be at the start to be like are we set up
for success do we have the right scope
to make sure that I think the goal is
clear what are we doing yeah what are we
doing what's our goal what success
what's not success exactly and and
different points we'll check in to make
sure things are going well because it's
easy a dick
sometimes better to come in from a
somewhat outside perspective you haven't
been thinking about this really gnarly
problem really hard for the last two
days and we can come in go well you know
maybe we could think about it this way
or maybe we don't have to do it that way
we could try another way so that helps
and then at the end we've you know if
something's built then we can also work
with the marketing team to make sure
that it gets out to users we can test it
with users and help make sure that this
is what users want and and if there's
some feedback on it saying actually you
know this little bit tricky to
understand or we really don't like the
look of that then we can say okay for
the next revision let's let's fix that
and and have you always been a product
manager know what's your background yeah
before this yeah I was doing a bit of a
strange route to get here out of school
and I had no idea what I wanted to do
and so I do management consulting which
is what a lot of people do when they
don't know what they want to do so
that's you're working on a bunch of very
different projects for different
companies just trying to solve something
for them should we enter this market
what should we do to stop this product
from failing all those things and that
was in Sydney and and I loved it and it
helped me figure out what I really
wanted to do when I worked on a couple
education projects and just realized
this is by far the biggest social lever
that we could ever have
I want to work on that and maximize my
impact and it was super rewarding as
well so if you're being pretty selfish
it's a fun thing to work on personally
so after that I just went after things
that I thought could have a big impact
in education did some stuff with Teach
for Australia when it was starting up
then worked for an impact investing
funds that was looking into getting into
education in developing world and then I
moved to a specific education fund that
was investing in low-cost private
schools in India now which is rich is
fantastic because that's you know where
people need it the most and really
interesting that would have required a
bunch of travel and I wasn't really
ready for that doors of family so it's
like okay how can we have really big
impact in education but not have to
travel have a much better lifestyle
technology's doing a pretty good job of
that I've heard of some things like Khan
Academy and yeah I came out we moved out
here to the Bay Area and to work at a
place like this and this was probably my
dream job and yeah maybe six months or
nine months later yeah roll came open
and opportunity was there and and I
started off doing email marketing that
was the first thing I came in to do
because we yeah we didn't have a way to
email our 7 million users at the time
and had to figure out how to do that and
that kind of snowballed into a bunch of
other marketing product marketing
working on growth and then found myself
working on on the product which is fun
because I've always been pretty
opinionated about the product and now
it's quite scary having to be
responsible and what it what advice
would you have for someone who wants to
do what you're doing it's very hard to
anticipate exactly what you do as a
product manager so the advice some of
the advice would be just get get as much
experience being involved in making
projects happen as possible as much as
possible as you can and so consulting is
really good for that because they're
always projects that have a pretty clear
scope and you've got a deliver and
that's similar to doing making products
but if you're a designer or
engineer or you would like to do each of
those things I'm doing that for a period
of time and then being part of the
product development process and then
thinking oh you know I'd like to also be
part of the broader hand process around
product not just designer engineering
that's a it's a great way to get into it
I think that some of the best folks can
do that coming from a user research
background if you really like conducting
surveys and interviews with folks and
then you get to really emphasize with
the user and that's that's probably the
most important piece so I think you need
a spike in in one of those areas so you
need to understand the development
process or the design process or the
user research process or the analytics
side of things I was doing a bunch of
that understanding the data how our
users were interacting on the site and
that's one of the strong lenses that I
take when I think about the product and
then all you need to do is have decent
process management skills like making
sure you know how things are moving and
are they happening right and your you'll
be a great product manager if you can do
that we're great well thank you for
explaining that